>>From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> GOOD EVENING, EVERYONE.
I FEEL LIKE I'M THE LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS'S TOKEN NERD
TO DO ALL THESE WELCOMES WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR SUPERHERO EVENTS.
GOOD EVENING, ON BEHALF OF
THE LIBRARIAN OF CONGRESS,
CLARLA HAYDEN, I
AM ROSWELL ENCINA,
THE CHIEF COMMUNICATIONS
OFFICER AND WELCOME
TO THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
WE'RE HERE TO CELEBRATE
A VERY SPECIAL BIRTHDAY.
THIS MAY, WE ARE CELEBRATING
THE 80th ANNIVERSARY OF THE MAN
OF STEEL HIMSELF, SUPERMAN.
YEAH. YOU CAN CLAP.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IN 80 YEARS, HE HAS RESCUED
LOIS LANE COUNTLESS OF TIMES,
SAVED THE UNIVERSE, BRAINIAC
AND DOOMSDAY MORE
THAN I CAN REMEMBER.
HAS DIED, RETURNED
AND HAS BEEN BORN.
HE'S PART OF THE AMERICAN
FABRIC AS MUCH AS APPLE PIE
AND BASEBALL, JUST
LOOK AT THE SET.
WE'VE OUTDID OURSELVES TONIGHT.
I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME MY
PARENTS BOUGHT ME MY FIRST BATCH
OF DC COMIC BOOKS.
IT INCLUDED THE BATMAN FAMILY,
AND ACTION COMICS
FEATURING SUPERMAN.
AS A KID AS MOST OF YOU KNOW
YOU WERE EITHER A DC READER
OR A MARVEL READER.
SUPERMAN, BATMAN, WONDER WOMAN,
AQUA MAN, GREEN LAN EARN,
I COULD GO ON AND ON BUT AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED, MY LOYALTY WAS
WITH ANYONE SUPERMAN
WAS FRIENDS WITH.
I REMEMBER WATCHING RERUNS OF
OLD EPISODES OF THE ADVENTURES
OF SUPERMAN STARTING
GEORGE REEVES.
I PRACTICALLY MEMBER
RIDES EVERY EPISODE
OF THE CARTOON ANIMATED
SERIES SUPER FRIENDS
SO WHEN THE FIRST EVER SUPERHERO
BLOCKBUSTER MOVIE SUPERMAN
STARRING CHRISTOPHER REEVE WAS
OUT, I WAS FLYING HIGH JUST
LIKE THE MAN OF STEEL HIMSELF.
SINCE THEN I THINK I'VE SEEN
EVERY VERSION OF SUPERMAN
ON THE SMALL AND BIG SCREEN,
FROM SMALLVILLE TO SUPERGIRL,
FROM CHRISTOPHER
REEVE TO HENRY CAVILL.
IT'S SAFE TO SAY I
GREW UP WITH SUPERMAN
AND CLEARLY DRANK THE
DC COMICS COOL AID.
WORKING HERE HAS BROUGHT ME TO
A NEW LEVEL OF MY SIP NERDINESS.
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS HAS ONE
OF THE LARGEST COMIC
BOOK COLLECTIONS
IN THE WORLD, IN THE WORLD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
PREVIEW ON YOUR WAY OUT,
OUTSIDE THE AUDITORIUM
HEAR, YOU'LL SEE A LITTLE
OF THE LIBRARY'S COLLECTION
INCLUDING SOME SUPERMAN COMIC
BOOKS THAT DATE BACK TO THE 40s.
I KNOW YOU'LL HAVE
FUN WITH THAT.
AND YES, THE LIBRARY HAS THE
FIRST DRAFT OF THE DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE, LINCOLN'S
DRAFT INAUGURAL ADDRESS.
A LOCK OF BEETHOVEN'S HAIR AND
ALEXANDER HAMILTON'S PAPERS
BUT ON MY FIRST THING HERE
THE ONLY THING I WANTED
TO SEE WAS THE FIRST
EDITION OF BATMAN,
SUPERMAN AND WONDER WOMAN.
SO CARLA HAYDEN PROMISED TO MAKE
THE COLLECTION MORE ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC.
LAST YEAR WE HAD OUR
FIRST POP-UP EXHIBIT
OF THESE COMIC BOOKS INCLUDING A
SPECIAL EVENT WITH LINDA CARTER
IN COLLABORATION WITH
AWESOME CON HERE IN DC.
THIS YEAR WE'RE EXCITED
TO DO IT AGAIN,
AS WASHINGTON HOSTS AWESOME
CON 2018 THIS WEEKEND,
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS
WANTS TO BRING DC TO DC
TO CELEBRATE THE MAN OF
STEEL'S 80th BIRTHDAY.
WE HAVE SOME SPECIAL
GUESTS FOR YOU TONIGHT.
WE HAVE PAUL LEVITZ, THE
FORMER PUBLISHER AND PRESIDENT
OF DC COMICS, WHO LED THE DC
COMICS DIVISION OF TIME WARNER
AS ITS SENIOR BUSINESS
OFFICER FOR THREE DECADES.
DURING THAT TIME, HE
WAS INTIMATELY INVOLVED
IN GROWING THE COMPANY
INTO A CULTURAL FORCE,
WITH MEDIA SUCCESSES
AS DIVERSE WITH ONE
OF THE HIGHEST GROSSING COMIC
BOOK FILMS EVER THE DARK KNIGHT
AND THE LONGEST RUNNING
COMIC BOOK TELEVISION
SERIES SMALLVILLE.
ALSO JOINING US IS WRITER
AND ARTIST DAN JURGENS,
THE FORCE BEHIND A TEN YEAR RUN
AS WRITER ARTIST OF SUPERMAN,
INCLUDING THE BEST
SELLING DEATH OF SUPERMAN
FOR WHICH HE WON THE NATIONAL
SOCIETY AWARD FOR BEST
IN COMIC BOOK DIVISION.
MODERATING TONIGHT IS
DAVID BENECORT A WRITER
FOR THE WASHINGTON POST WHOSE
TWITTER HANDLE IS@A DC FAN BOY.
HE ALSO WRITES ABOUT ALL
ASPECTS OF COMIC BOOK CULTURE.
SO LET'S GIVE THEM
A BIG DC WELCOME.
AS THEY SAY, IT'S A
BIRD, IT'S A PLANE,
WE'RE ALL ABOUT SUPERMAN
TONIGHT.
PLEASE WELCOME PAUL LEVITZ, DAN
JURGENS, AND PAUL BENNY COURT.
>> HELLO EVERYONE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TONIGHT
AS A NATIVE WASHINGTONIAN
AND A HUGE COMIC BOOK FAN, IT'S
A VERY SPECIAL NIGHT FOR ME.
MY DAD'S IN THE AUDIENCE,
AS WELL.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE CHARACTER
WE'LL TALK ABOUT SUPERMAN,
WHO GOES BY MANY
NAMES, THE MAN OF STEEL,
KALEL, CLARK JOSEPH KENT.
HE GOES BY A LOT OF THINGS
BUT THIS IS THE CHARACTER,
THIS CURRENT ERA WE'RE SEEING
WHERE COMIC BOOK CULTURE
HAS TAKEN OVER SO MUCH
OF THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY,
WE FIND IT IN LIVE
ACTION TELEVISION, MOVIES,
ANIMATION, YOU NAME IT.
THAT ALL GETS A START
BECAUSE OF THE CREATION
OF THIS CHARACTER WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT TODAY.
VERY HONORED TO BE HERE BESIDE
PAUL LEVITZ, FORMER EDITOR --
I'M SORRY, FORMER PRESIDENT
AND PUBLISHER OF DC COMICS
AND DAN JURGENS, A
WRITER AND ARTIST
WHO PROBABLY IS MOST KNOWN
FOR BEING THE MAN
THAT KILLED SUPERMAN.
I REMEMBER --
[ LAUGHTER ]
FONDLY BEING 12 YEARS OLD
AND READING THAT ISSUE,
THAT LAST PANEL, WHERE
LOIS IS HOLDING HIM
AND SHE BASICALLY
RELIES ON HIS ARM.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WAS YESTERDAY.
IT WAS A LONG TIME AGO.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
YOU GUYS HERE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> PAUL, I WANT TO
START WITH YOU.
DO YOU THINK IT SAYS SOMETHING
ABOUT THE CONTINUED RELEVANCE
OF SUPERMAN THAT
A SERIES CREATED
SO LONG AGO IS NOT ONLY STILL
AROUND, BUT HAS MANAGED TO REACH
IN THE COMIC BOOK
INDUSTRY IN TERMS
OF PUBLISHING A VERY
ICONIC 1000th ISSUE?
>> THERE'S VERY LITTLE THAT
WAS CULTURALLY RELEVANT
IN 1938 THAT'S STILL
CULTURALLY RELEVANT TODAY.
THERE A FEW THINGS WE
LOOK BACK ON AS SORT
OF WONDERFUL ARTIFACTS
OF THE TIME.
JUDY GARLAND WIZARD OF OZ MOVIES
IS ABOUT A MINUTE AFTER THAT,
BUT HERE'S SOMETHING
THAT WAS CREATED THEN
THAT IS STILL A LIVING, GROWING,
CHANGING PART OF THE CULTURE.
DAN'S WRITING IT AGAIN,
NEW MOVIES ARE BEING MADE,
NEW TELEVISION SERIES,
KRYPTON STARTED A WEEK AGO,
LOOKING AT A DIFFERENT ASPECT
OF THE CHARACTER'S LIFE.
THAT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
THING IN A CULTURE
THAT HAS THE ATTENTION
SPAN OF A MAYFLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND WE'VE SEEN THROUGH
THOSE 80 YEARS
THAT WHERE BEING
DISTRACTED CONSTANTLY
BY THE NEW, THE EXCITING.
YOU HAVE SO MANY
THOUSANDS OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO FIND NEW THINGS WHETHER
IT'S NEW TELEVISION SHOWS,
NEW COMIC SERIES, NEW LITTLE
SELF-PUBLISHED BOOKS THAT TURN
INTO 50 SHADES OF GREY, TO
HAVE SOMETHING BE CONSISTENTLY
IMPORTANT TO THE
CULTURE THROUGH ALL
THAT TIME IS JUST ANT
ABSOLUTELY UNIQUE PHENOMENON.
>> DAN, WHAT'S IT LIKE
FOR YOU TO BE A PART
OF THE ACTION COMICS LEGACY NOW?
A LOT OF US I KNOW FROM MY YOUTH
I REMEMBER YOU AND YOUR TIME
ON THE SUPERMAN TITLE,
BUT YOU'RE CURRENTLY
WRITING ACTION COMICS.
YOUR RUN WILL COME TO AN END
WITH THE STAND ALONE
STORY IN ISSUE 1,000.
YOU'VE BEEN LEADING THE
MARCH TO THE 1000th ISSUE.
BACK WHEN YOU WERE DOING
SUPERMAN IN THE 90s, THE DEATH
AND RETURN OF SUPERMAN,
THAT'S AROUND THE TIME
WHERE ACTION WAS HOVERING
AROUND 700 ISSUES.
COULD YOU HAVE IMAGINED
BACK THEN IN THE EARLY '90s
THAT YOU'D BE HERE IN 2018?
>> NO, NO, THERE'S NO WAY.
SO MUCH OF IT IS WHEN
YOU'RE INVOLVED WITH TRYING
TO PRODUCE STORY, YOU ARE
TRYING TO PRODUCE STORY
AND IT'S JUST TRYING TO FASHION
A GOOD STORY TO GET IT DONE,
TO SEE IT GET TO THE POINT WHERE
IT'S PRINTED AND ON THE STAND
AND AS A WRITER OFTEN YOU
BUILD STORY IN TERMS OF ART,
SO YOU'RE PLANNING 5, 8,
10 OR 12 ISSUES AHEAD.
AT LEAST I'M NOT AND I
DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO IS
WHO IS THINKING 20 YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD OR 30,
AND THE COMIC BOOK NUMBERING
SYSTEM IT JUST SEAMS SO FAR OFF.
IT'S LIKE NO, WE NEVER TALKED
ABOUT ACTION 1,000 NOR DID I
THINK WE EVER REALLY GAVE IT
ANY THOUGHT.
>> I'LL SAY I VERY NERDILY
GAVE IT SOME THOUGHT.
I ACTUALLY REMEMBER BUYING
ACTION COMIC 700 AND TRYING
TO CALCULATE AND ENDED
UP BEING A WRITER
SO MATH WASN'T A STRONG POINT.
I REMEMBER TRYING TO THINK WOW,
WHAT YEAR WILL 1,000 COME OUT.
>> ARE YOU CLOSE?
DID YOU HAVE IT?
>> I WAS OFF BY A LITTLE BIT.
>> AS TOO FORMER
PUBLISHER AND PRESIDENT
OF DC COMICS WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO THE NOTION
THAT SUPERMAN IS
TOO HARD OF A STORY?
IS THE KEY TO A GOOD STORY
A VILLAIN AS POWERFUL
AS DOOMSDAY OR DARK SIDE?
OR IS PART OF WHAT MAKES PEOPLE
COME BACK IS THE FACT HE HAS A
HUMAN SIDE, HAVING
GROWN UP IN KANSAS,
BEING DOWN TO EARTH
DESPITE BEING SO POWERFUL?
>> TO TO ME THE STRONGEST PART
OF SUPERMAN HAS BEEN
THE EMOTIONAL PART
AND HIS REPRESENTATION
AS AN ICONIC MORAL FIGURE
THAT THIS IS SOMEONE WHO
HAS THESE INCREDIBLE GIFTS
AND IS USING THEM
FOR THE RIGHT CAUSES.
SOME YEARS AGO WE HAD A GROUP OF
ARAB EDITORIAL CARTOONISTS COME
TO VISIT DC, MOSTLY THEY WANT
TO SEE THE M.A.D. MAGAZINE GUYS
AND SAY, THEY DON'T PUT
YOU IN JAIL FOR DOING THIS?
BUT THEY MADE THE
POINT, THEY SAID,
ISN'T THE SUPERHERO
IDEA A REFLECTION
OF THE AMERICAN BELIEF
THAT MIGHT MAKES RIGHT?
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT
IT FOR A MOMENT OR TWO
AND I SAID I CAN SEE WHERE YOU
SEE THAT IN THE SUPER HEAR ROWS
BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE CASE.
I THINK WHAT THE
SUPERHEROS AND CERTAINLY
IN PARTICULAR SUPERMAN SAYS
TO US IS THAT WE'RE ALL BORN
WITH CERTAIN GIFTS AND IT'S WHAT
WE DO WITH THEM, HOW WE CHOOSE
TO USE THEM THAT DETERMINES
HOW THE WORLD GROWS,
HOW THE WORLD CHANGES,
AND WHO WE ARE.
I THINK THOSE ARE
THE GREAT STORIES.
YOU SEE SUPERMAN USING
HIS POWER IN A WAY
THAT CHANGES AN INDIVIDUAL
PERSON'S LIFE.
>> DAN, I SAVED A VERY SERIOUS
QUESTION FOR YOU, THE TRUNKS.
>> I KNEW THAT WAS COMING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AS SOMEONE WHO HAS NOT ONLY
WRITTEN BUT ILLUSTRATED SUPERMAN
AS WELL, NOW, I REMEMBER
NEW 52, THE TRUNKS GO AWAY.
IT WAS KIND OF ALIGNED
WITH HENRY CATTLE'S
DEBUT AS THE MAN OF SPIT.
THAT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE YOU MAY
HAVE YOUNG KIDS DISCOVERING THIS
CHARACTER FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND IF THEY WANT TO JUMP
TO THE COMICS YOU WANT IT TO
LOOK AS SIMILAR AS POSSIBLE
BUT IT WAS A CONTROVERSIAL
DECISION.
ONE OF THE BIG GUEST THINGS
CELEBRATED WITH ACTION 1,000,
BOTH THIS 80th ANNIVERSARY
EDITION
AND YOUR PERIODICAL EDITION IS
THE FACT THE TRUNKS ARE BACK.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
DRAWN SUPERMAN,
AND YOU'VE BEEN DRAWING
HIM TRUNKLESS
IN ACTION LEADING
UP TO THIS POINT.
>> CAREFUL HOW YOU PHRASE THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I MEAN, COME ON.
>> DID YOU EVER HAVE
MUSCLE MEMORY MOMENTS
WHEN YOU WERE DRAWING HIM FULLY
CLOTHED WITHOUT THE TRUNKS?
>> ALL THE TIME.
IF YOU WERE TO SEE THE
UNDERDRAWING THAT WAS THERE,
BECAUSE THE WAY I WORK IS
FIRST I SKETCH THINGS OUT.
THEY'RE ALWAYS THERE.
THEY WERE ALWAYS THERE, AND IT'S
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE MATE SAY
IT'S BECAUSE I DREW SO MUCH
OF SUPERMAN WHEN HE HAS THEM.
OTHERS SAY IT FITS WELL, THE
APPEARANCE OF THE CHARACTER.
I'VE ALWAYS SAID A
COUPLE OF THINGS.
ONE, WE ALWAYS SAW THE
TRUNKS AS PART OF THE UNIFORM
AS THOUGH IT WAS ALL ONE PIECE
AND NOT NECESSARILY SOMETHING
HE PUT ON THE OUTSIDE
BUT THE OTHER PART IS I THINK
IT'S THE YELLOW BELT AND EVEN
WHEN THEY WENT WITHOUT
THE TRUNKS WE PLAYED
AROUND WITH A YELLOW S SHIELD
FOR A BELT BUCKLE OR A WAY
TO GET A LITTLE YELLOW
IN THE MID RANGE
BECAUSE THAT HELPED HIGHLIGHT
THAT BRILLIANT TRIANGULAR
SHE SAID WITH THE S IN IT
AND ULTIMATELY I THINK THAT'S
WHY THE TRUNKS ARE NEEDED IS
MORE BECAUSE OF THE YELLOW BELT
BECAUSE THAT PULLS THE WHOLE
UNIFORM TOGETHER FOR ME.
>> PAUL, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHT ON THE TRUNKS?
WOULD YOU HAVE GONE
WITH THAT DECISION?
>> I'M A PRO-TRUNKS
GUY IN ALL OF THIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
PLEASE DULY NOTE TRUNKS DID NOT
DISAPPEAR UNTIL AFTER I WAS AWAY
FROM THE EXECUTIVE DESK
AND IF WE GO OFF THE
MIC LATER I CAN TELL YOU
WHO GOT THE TRUNKS OFF,
AND IT'S NOT WHO YOU THINK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND THE TRUNKS ARE BACK.
IT IS HASHTAG THE
TRUNKS ARE BACK, RIGHT?
>> THERE YOU GO, IT'S
TRENDING FOR SURE.
PAUL, IN THIS EDITION
THAT YOU'VE EDITED THE 80th
ANNIVERSARY EDITION YOU WORKED
WITH MAR IF WOLFMAN ON
THIS ININDIVIDUALIBLE STORY
OF UNPUBLISHED STORY,
THE CREATORS OF SUPERMAN.
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT IT WAS
LIKE, FIRST FINDING OUT ABOUT
THAT AND THEN WORKING WITH IT?
>> WELL, THE GUYS AT DC ASKED ME
TO PUT TOGETHER THIS
CELEBRATORY HARD COVER,
AND GAVE ME SOME TOOLS TO WORK
WITH THAT THEY DON'T USUALLY
OFFER EDITORS OF REPRINT TITLES
SO I WAS ABLE TO REACH OUT
TO A NUMBER OF UNUSUAL PEOPLE
TO ADD THEIR COMMENTS AND THEIR
THOUGHTS, WHICH WAS GREAT FUN.
THERE'S A PIECE IN HERE
BY LAURA SIEGEL LARSON,
JERRY SIEGEL'S DAUGHTER, TALKING
ABOUT HER DAD AND HIS MEMORIES
OF CREATION OF SUPERMAN AND
HIS ATTITUDES TOWARDS IT
THAT WAS A REALLY
WONDERFUL THING FOR ME,
BECAUSE IT'S NO SECRET THERE
WERE MANY YEARS OF LEGAL BATTLES
BETWEEN SIEGEL AND SCHUSTER AND
AND DC THAT HAVE GOTTEN RESOLVED
AT THIS POINT AND REALLY
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE LAURA
IN HERE WAS A WAY OF
CLOSURE IN SOME FASHION.
JULES PHIFER, WHO'S REALLY
AN AMERICAN TREASURE,
ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE WHO'S WON
A PULITZER, AN OSCAR, AN OBIE,
I THINK EVERYTHING
BUT THE LOTTERY.
AND HE'S ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE
HIS MEMORIES OF ACTION ONE,
AS A KID WHO BOUGHT THEM,
AND WENT ON TO BE THIS GREAT
CARTOONIST IN HIS OWN RIGHT.
BUT AS I WAS ASSEMBLING
THE BOOK, I REMEMBERED
THAT MARV WOLFMAN, WHO'S A DEAR
FRIEND OF MANY, MANY YEARS,
HAD SALVAGED A SIEGEL AND
SCHUSTER STORY THAT DC WAS GOING
TO THROW OUT UNPUBLISHED
WHEN HE WAS A KID.
IN THE OLD DAYS WHEN YOU
CAME UP TO DC OFFICES,
ORIGINAL ART WASN'T PERCEIVED
TO BE WORTH ANYTHING.
I'M SORRY, DAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THOUGH THIS IS BEFORE
ANY OF IT WAS YOURS.
>> I KNOW, YEAH.
>> AND THEY WOULD, YOU KNOW,
LIKE IT WAS TRICK OR TREAT.
HERE LITTLE BOY, YOU
CAME UP FOR A TOUR.
WOULD YOU LIKE A PAGE OF ART?
THE ARTISTS THEMSELVES
COULDN'T GET THE ARTWORK BACK
BECAUSE IT WAS PRESUMED THEY
WOULD SOMEHOW GO SELL IT
TO SOMEBODY ELSE
TO BE PUBLISHED.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO WORK
BUT IF YOU WERE A KID
TOURING YOU COULD GET IT,
AND MARV ON ONE OCCASION
SALVAGED THIS STORY THAT WAS
ABOUT TO BE DESTROYED AND
HE'D HAD IT IN HIS HOUSE,
AND I SPOKE TO HIM AND SAID:
SO THE STORY YOU'VE HAD
HIDDEN AWAY ALL THESE YEARS,
WOULD YOU MIND HAVING
IT PUBLISHED?
DO YOU THINK THAT WILL
DECREASE THE VALUE OF IT,
OR INCREASE THE VALUE OF IT?
DO YOU WANT TO CHECK THAT
WITH AN ART DEALER BEFORE WE
GO AHEAD?
AND HE SAID: NO, NO, I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE IT PUBLISHED,
HAPPY TO TELL THE STORY
OF HOW I SAVED SUPERMAN,
IS HOW HE PHRASED IT
IN HIS TEXT PIECE HERE.
IT'S NOT AN EXTRAORDINARY
STORY IN BEING, LIKE,
THE GREAT CLASSIC
SUPERMAN STORY.
THERE'S A REASON THEY WEREN'T
ABOUT TO PUBLISH IT THAT DAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT IT'S A MAGNIFICENT
ARTIFACT TO BE ABLE TO SEE SORT
OF THE WORK IN PROGRESS, AND
IT'S PRETTY CLOSE TO THE END
OF JERRY'S WRITING OF SUPERMAN,
PRETTY CLOSE TO THE END
OF WHEN THE SCHUSTER STUDIO
WAS CREATING THE MATERIAL
AND YOU REALLY SEE WHAT
THE PROCESS WAS LIKE,
AND WE REPRODUCED THAT
IN BLACK AND WHITE,
SO IT DOESN'T HAVE THE
ADVANTAGES AND THE MASKING
OF COLOR ON TOP OF IT SO IT
FEELS MORE LIKE AN ARTIFACT.
>> DAN, YOUR RUN ON ACTION
COMICS COMES TO AN END
WITH THE 1000th ISSUE.
THAT WILL BE OUT IN APRIL.
>> FOR NOW.
I'VE COME BACK BEFORE.
>> WAS RETURNING TO
SUPERMAN IN THIS NEW ERA
OF COMICS WHAT YOU
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE,
HOW DID YOU FEEL WRAPPING
UP THIS CURRENT STORY
LINE IN ACTION COMICS?
AND MOST OF US KNOW HERE,
BRIAN MICHAEL BENNETT WILL
BE TAKING OVER WITH 1001.
ARE YOU EXCITED FOR THAT?
>> YEAH, DEFINITELY.
I'VE TALKED TO BRIAN A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT HE HAS IN STORY
AND I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE GOOD.
I LOOK FORWARD TO
IT AS A READER.
AS FOR WINDING IT UP, I THINK
TO COME BACK TO IT A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO AND BE ABLE
TO WRITE IT AS A BOOK
THAT WAS COMING OUT TWICE
A MONTH WAS A LOT OF FUN,
BECAUSE AT THAT POINT
YOU CAN PLAY
AROUND WITH STORYTELLING
TECHNIQUE A LITTLE BIT.
NORMALLY WHAT YOU HAVE TO
DO IS PUT AN ISSUE OUT THERE
AND ANTICIPATE SOMEONE
REMEMBERING WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT 30 DAYS LATER.
AND WHEN YOU HAD A BOOK
THAT CAME OUT TWICE A MONTH,
YOU COULD PLAY AROUND WITH
SOME IDEAS A LITTLE MORE
AND YOU COULD DIG A LITTLE
DEEPER IN SOME THINGS,
JUST KNOWING THAT THE READERS
WOULD HAVE A MORE FRESH MEMORY
OF WHAT YOU JUST DID.
SO IT WAS NICE TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT THAT WAY.
>> TALKING ABOUT
SUPERMAN THIS WHOLE TIME.
LET'S TALK ABOUT CLARK
KENT FOR A SECOND.
THERE'S THIS NOTION THAT
POPS UP EVERY NOW AND THEN
THAT CLARK KENT IS JUST
WHO SUPERMAN PRETENDS TO BE
WHEN HE WANTS TO
NOT BE BOTHERED.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S NOT THE
OPINION OF YOUR HARD CORE FAN,
WE ALL KNOW THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
>> RIGHT.
>> IN THE COMICS, HE'S CLARK
FROM THE MOMENT HE LANDS
IN KANSAS IN THE SHIP.
WHEN CRAFTING STORIES FOR
SUPERMAN, THIS IS A QUESTION
FOR BOTH OF YOU, IS IT IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THE MAN HE WAS,
CLARK KENT, WHO WAS AROUND
LONG BEFORE ANYONE EVER STARTED
CALLING HIM SUPERMAN?
>> I THINK SO.
I MEAN, I HAVE ALWAYS
SEEN THAT AS THE CORE
OF WHO SUPERMAN REALLY IS, THAT
-- THIS GETS INTO THE WHOLE IDEA
OF PEOPLE SOMETIMES ASK:
WAS HE SUPERMAN FIRST?
OR WAS HE CLARK KENT FIRST?
I'M NOT SURE YOU
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THE TWO.
HE IS CLARK KENT, AND IN A
LOT OF WAYS, WHAT HE DOES
AS CLARK KENT, OR IT'S THE SAME
FOR LOIS LANE, IS THEY'RE TRYING
TO MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE IN WHAT THEY DO
THROUGH THEIR JOBS,
THROUGH THEIR CAREERS.
AND I THINK THERE'S A REASON
HE CHOSE THAT FOR A CAREER.
AND BY THE SAME WAY OF THINKING,
I THINK THEN BEING
SUPERMAN IS SORT
OF AN EXTENSION OF THAT INTENT.
SO IT'S NO DIFFERENT
IN SOME WAYS
THAN IF YOUR NEXT-DOOR
NEIGHBOR WAS A POLICE OFFICER
OR FIREFIGHTER.
THEY'RE NOT TWO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
IT IS, THIS IS WHAT I
DO WHEN I'M AT HOME,
AND THIS IS WHAT I DO WHEN
I GO DO THIS OTHER THING.
THAT'S HOW I'VE ALWAYS SEEN IT.
>> AND I THINK THE OTHER PIECE
WHERE CLARK IS IMPORTANT IS
IN SOME WAYS CLARK IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF US.
WE HAVE THE INSECURITIES
OF BEING CLARK,
AND WE WISH THAT OUR LOVED ONES
WOULD USE THEIR VISION TO SEE
THROUGH THOSE INSECURITIES
TO OUR GOOD QUALITIES.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY
A FUNDAMENTAL PART
OF THE SUPERMAN MYTH.
JERRY VERY MUCH PUT HIMSELF
INTO THE CHARACTER THAT WAY
AND HE CAPTURED SOMETHING
IN ALL OF US.
WE ALL HAVE THOSE KIND
OF INSECURE MOMENTS.
>> WHENEVER I THINK ABOUT THAT,
I THINK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE RIGHT HERE OF MAN
OF STEEL FANTASTIC MINI SERIES
WRITTEN AND DRAWN BY JOHN BERN.
I REMEMBER THERE WAS A SCENE IN
THERE WHERE ONE OF HIS PARENTS,
I CAN'T REMEMBER IF IT WAS MA OR
PA, BUT THEY SAID TO SUPERMAN,
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT WEARING A MASK,
PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO THINK
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO HIDE.
SO DON'T WORRY ABOUT
THE FACT THAT, YES,
EVEN WHEN YOU PUT
THE GLASSES ON,
YOU STILL LOOK EXACTLY THE
SAME, BECAUSE NO ONE IS GOING
TO BE THINKING SUPERMAN
IS TRYING TO HIDE
BECAUSE HIS FACE IS NOT COVERED.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS GREAT
SUPERMAN HAS A SON NOW
WITH LOIS LANE, JONATHAN KENT,
WHO IS CURRENTLY SUPER-BOY.
CHARACTERS LIKE SUPERMAN
FOR A LONG TIME CHILDREN WERE
NEVER REALLY IN THE EQUATION
WHEN IT COMES TO CONTINUITY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
SUPERMAN BEING A FATHER, YES,
I DO KNOW BATMAN HAS A KID NOW.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
SUPERMAN BEING A FATHER
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN PART
OF TELLING JONATHAN'S STORY?
AND AS SOMEONE WHO
IS FROM AN ERA
WHERE THAT MIGHT
NOT HAVE BEEN TRIED,
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> AS THE YEARS GO ON, THE
CONTINUITIES GET MORE COMPLEX
AND THERE'S MORE ROOM TO DO
DIFFERENT KINDS OF STORIES.
THE SUPERMAN OF MY
TIME HADN'T GOTTEN
TO THE POINT OF HAVING KIDS.
THERE WERE LOTS OF
IMAGINARY STORIES THAT I READ
WHEN I WAS A CHILD THAT
IMAGINED WHAT IT WOULD BE
LIKE WHEN SUPERMAN
MIGHT HAVE CHILDREN.
IT WAS REALLY FUN WHEN
I WAS 7, 8, 9 YEARS OLD,
SO I CAN CERTAINLY IMAGINE
THAT THE STORIES TODAY ARE
FUN FOR PEOPLE TO READ.
IT'S NOT MY MOMENT.
WE GET FROZEN IN THE CHARACTERS,
AS WE LOVE THEM BEST,
AND WHEN I WANT THE
CHARACTER AS I LOVED HIM BEST,
I GO BACK TO THE STUFF I WAS
READING WHEN I WAS 10 OR 12.
DOESN'T MAKE IT BETTER
THAN WHAT'S BEING DONE NOW.
JUST IT REMINDS ME OF WHAT CANDY
STORE I WAS IN WHEN I FOUND
THAT ISSUE, OR WHERE I WAS
AT CAMP AND REACTING TO IT.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
POWER OF THE COMIC BOOK FORM.
SO I'M GOING TO STICK TO SORT
OF MY MEMORIES AS THE HEART
AND SOUL OF IT, AND NOT PASS
JUDGMENT FOR GOOD OR FOR ILL
ON WHAT'S BEING DONE
FOR A LATER GENERATION.
>> YEARS AGO, WHEN CLARK AND
LOIS FINALLY GOT ENGAGED,
AND THEN GOT MARRIED, WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT:
WOULD WE EVER DO STORIES
WHERE THEY BECOME PARENTS?
AND WE SAID: WELL, IT TOOK
THEM 50 YEARS TO GET MARRIED,
SO 50 YEARS FROM
NOW, WE'LL GET TO IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I THINK WITH THIS ONE, THE
IDEA WAS THAT IT ALLOWS US
TO TELL A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT KIND OF A STORY
WITH SUPERMAN, THAT IF SUPERMAN
IS OUT THERE SERVING IN TERMS
OF A BEACON OF HOPE AND
INSPIRATION, AND SUDDENLY TRYING
TO GUIDE THOSE AROUND HIM,
WOULD IT BE FUN TO DO STORIES
WHERE WE SEE HIM TRYING
TO DO THAT AS A PARENT?
IS THERE SOME KIND
OF DUALITY THERE?
BECAUSE IDEALLY AS A
PARENT, YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO THE EXACT SAME
THING, RIGHT?
YOU'RE TRYING TO SET AN
EXAMPLE, SET A STANDARD,
AND HOPE THAT PEOPLE FOLLOW YOU.
SO I KNOW WHEN WE FIRST
TALKED ABOUT IT, I SAID,
IN A WAY THIS CAN KIND OF
REPRESENT SOME OF THAT.
IT CAN KIND OF REPRESENT
SOMETHING OF THE FUTURE
AND I THINK THERE ARE NEW
STORIES TO TELL WITH IT.
SO THAT'S WHY WE
WENT AND HAD IT DONE.
I HAD GREAT FUN WITH IT.
I THINK IT'S WORKED WELL.
>> YOU ENJOY WRITING
WITH JONATHAN?
>> I ENJOY WRITING FOR JONATHAN
BECAUSE I THINK TWO
THINGS HAPPEN.
THERE WAS A FEEL THAT SUPERMAN
WOULD INSTANTLY FEEL OLD
AND STODGY.
THERE'S ALWAYS THIS FEAR
ABOUT SUPERMAN FEELING
OLD AND STODGY ANYWAY.
SO I SAID LET'S EMBRACE IT
AND MAKE THE BEST OF IT,
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
HAVING THAT FUN SENSE
OF YOUTH WHICH I THINK IS JON.
IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT
VERSION OF SUPER BOY IN A WAY.
IT'S A SUPER BOY FOR THE NOW.
>> CAN YOU GUYS TALK ABOUT,
THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT VERSIONS
OF ACTION 1,000, THE CELEBRATORY
COMMEMORATIVE EDITION YOU PUT
TOGETHER, AND ALSO
THE PERIODICAL
WHICH YOU'VE BEEN WRITING
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO?
AND WHAT IT WAS LIKE WORKING
ON THEM FOR BOTH OF YOU?
>> SURE. I THINK DAN HAD
THE MORE CLASSIC OPPORTUNITY
IN THE SENSE THAT HE WAS
GETTING TO DO ACTION 1,000.
WHEN THAT ISSUE COMES
OUT IT HAS HIS NAME ON IT
AND THAT'S SERIOUSLY COOL.
WHAT I GOT TO DO WAS
TO BE A HISTORIAN.
BE SOMEONE WHO COULD
USE KNOWLEDGE
OF HOW THE CHARACTER HAD
EVOLVED, USE KNOWLEDGE
OF WHO THE PEOPLE WERE WHO WOULD
HAVE INTERESTING THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT THE CHARACTER,
AND BRING THEM TOGETHER
FOR THAT CELEBRATION.
I GOT TO THROW THE PARTY TO
CELEBRATE WHAT HE WAS DOING.
>> IT WAS A GREAT PARTY.
>> THANK YOU.
WE GOT SOME PRETTY COOL
PEOPLE AT THE PARTY
AND THEY LOOKED BACK AND
THEY PUT THE PIECES TOGETHER,
AND WE EXAMINED THE
DIFFERENT ERAS
AND REPRESENTED THE
DIFFERENT THINGS IN CONTEXT
AND IT'S TERRIFIC TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT KIND OF CELEBRATION.
I'M UTTERLY JEALOUS OF ACTUALLY
GETTING TO DO THE STORY ITSELF,
BUT IT'S GREAT JUST TO BE
ABLE TO THROW THE PARTY.
>> AND, DAN, FOR YOU,
WITH THE 1000th ISSUE,
YOURS WRAPS IT SELF
UP WITH ISSUE 999.
BUT GETTING TO THAT 1000th ISSUE
WHICH HAS MANY CONTRIBUTORS.
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO YOURSELF?
OKAY, I HAVE ONE LITTLE
PIECE OF THIS HISTORIC COMIC.
SOMETHING THAT'S
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE,
A COMIC REACHING 1,000 ISSUES.
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO YOURSELF
YOU WANTED TO PUT IN YOUR STORY?
>> I THINK I WANTED TO FIND A
WAY TO SAY "THANK YOU" IN A WAY.
WAY BACK WHEN, WHEN MAY
KIDS WERE REALLY LITTLE,
I TAUGHT THEM TO SAY SOMETHING
WHICH BASICALLY WENT THIS WAY,
WHAT IS SUPERMAN'S
GREATEST POWER?
I'D GET THEM TO SAY:
HE PAYS THE MORTGAGE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO I HAVE ALWAYS FELT THAT
HAVING HAD AN ASSOCIATION
WITH A CHARACTER LIKE SUPERMAN
THAT LONG, THAT I STARTED
TO THINK ALONG THE
LINES OF, YOU KNOW,
HOW DO YOU SAY "THANK YOU"?
AND IN MY STORY, IT'S
REALLY WHAT METROPOLIS DOES,
IS THEIR WAY OF THANKING
SUPERMAN.
YOU CAN'T GO OUT AND
BUY HIM A NEW CAR
OR GIVE HIM A CARIBBEAN
VACATION.
IT'S -- I WANTED TO WRITE
SOMETHING FROM THE HEART
AND EXPRESS THAT THROUGH
THE CITIZENS OF METROPOLIS
AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING FOR,
BECAUSE ACTION 1000 IS AN ICONIC
ISSUE AND THE STORIES I'VE READ
IN IT ARE TREMENDOUS
AND IT'S BEEN FUN
TO SEE IT COME TOGETHER.
I THINK IT REALLY IS
A VERY SPECIAL BOOK.
>> WHAT DOES THE NUMBER
1,000 MEAN TO BOTH OF YOU?
WE'RE IN A REALLY DIFFERENT
ERA IN THE COMIC BOOK INDUSTRY
WHERE THINGS KEEP REFRESHING
AND NUMBER-ONE ISSUE,
THAT'S THE BIG THING NOW TO
HAVE A NEW NUMBER-ONE ISSUE,
TO START OVER.
I REMEMBER ONCE TALKING
TO TODD McFARLAND, WHO,
A FORMER DC MARVEL
ARTIST CREATOR OF SPAWN,
HE ONCE TOLD ME HE NEVER THOUGHT
THAT HIS SPAWN COMIC
WOULD BE ONE
OF THE HEYEST NUMBERED
COMICS IN THE INDUSTRY,
JUST BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
WHEN WHEN NEW 52 CAME OUT
AND DC WENT TO NEW NUMBERING.
DOES THE NUMBER 1,000 BECAUSE
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE
IN COMICS, DOES IT HAVE
A SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU GUYS?
>> I WAS A COMIC BOOK COLLECTOR
BEFORE I WAS A COMIC BOOK
PROFESSIONAL, AND TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A 100 ISSUE RUN
OF ANYTHING WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
THING IN THOSE DAYS.
THERE WERE VERY FEW COMICS,
A DOZEN, TWO DOZEN, MAYBE,
THAT HAD HAD RUNS WHERE YOU
COULD HAVE 100-ISSUE RUN
THAT YOU COULD POSSIBLY COLLECT.
THE IDEA OF SOMETHING YOU COULD
HAVE 1,000 ISSUES IN A ROW OF,
JUST IS UTTERLY UNIMAGINABLE
TO THAT INNER KID IN ME.
AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY EXCITING.
>> I'D ALSO ADD THAT
WHEN I WAS A KID,
AND I'D BE AT A GENERAL
NEWS STAND --
THIS IS BEFORE COMIC SHOPS, SO
IT'S JUST GENERAL NEWSSTAND --
AND I COULD HOLD UP AN
ISSUE OF SPIDERMAN 63
AND BATMAN I DON'T KNOW 215,
SAY, I JUST FIGURED ANYTHING
THAT MADE IT TO 200
ISSUES MUST BE BETTER.
I THOUGHT THE HIGHER
NUMBER MEANT MORE QUALITY,
I REALLY DID.
SO 1,000 MUST BE PRETTY GOOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DAN, I HATE TO KEEP BRINGING
THIS BACK TO DEATH OF SUPERMAN
BUT THAT'S A HUGE REASON WHY I'M
HERE ON THIS STAGE RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE IT'S HOW MUCH THAT
STORY LINE IMPACTED ME IN TERMS
OF NOT JUST BEING A KID
WHO WENT TO 7 ELEVEN
AND GRABBED THE COPPIC TO
DRAW STUFF BUT ACTUALLY WANTED
TO READ A CONTINUING STORY.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE ASKED ME,
THERE'S ONE COMIC BOOK MOMENT
THAT WOULD PROBABLY NEVER BE
ADAPTED TO LIVE ACTION FILM,
I WOULD SAY IT WAS
KILLING SUPERMAN.
BUT WE ACTUALLY GOT TO SEE IT
HAPPEN, AND WHETHER YOU LIKED IT
OR NOT BATMAN VERSUS
SUPERMAN, DAWN OF JUSTICE.
NOW, I REMEMBER, BECAUSE
I LIKE TO PRIDE MYSELF
ON THINKING I CAN FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IN A MOVIE BECAUSE
I READ THE BOOKS.
I KNOW WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT EVEN WHEN THEY SHOWED
DOOMSDAY IN THE TRAILER,
I SAID OH, THAT'S COOL,
BUT THEY'RE NOT GONNA
KILL HIM, AND THEY DID IT.
THINK TO YOURSELF AND SAY:
WOW, I WASN'T EXPECTING
THAT TO EVER BE ADAPTED
INTO A MOVIE?
>> I THINK IN THE BACK OF
MY HEAD, BECAUSE RIGHT AWAY,
THERE WERE -- THERE WAS
BOTH A NOVELIZATION.
THEY ALSO DID AUDIO BOOKS OF IT
THAT I THOUGHT WE WOULD
EVENTUALLY GET THERE,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT HAD
COME UP EARLIER ANYWAY
WITH THE TIM BURTON FILM.
THEN THEY DID IT AS AN ANIMATED
MOVIE SO I THOUGHT YEAH,
WE MATE JUST GET THERE AT
SOME POINT SO WHAT WAS --
IT WAS COOL TO SEE IT DONE
BUT I THINK WHAT REALLY HIT ME
AS I WAS SITTING IN THE
MOVIE WAS THIS NOTION
THAT NOT ONLY DID THEY USE
DOOMSDAY OR THE STORY MATERIAL,
OR THE STORY IDEA, BUT THEY
ACTUALLY TRIED TO REPLICATE SOME
OF THE STUFF THAT I
HAD DRAWN ON FILM.
AND THAT WAS A VERY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE,
BECAUSE THAT I HADN'T
REALLY SEEN BEFORE.
AND TO SEE THEM TRY AND
REPRODUCE SOMETHING ON FILM
THAT I HAD DRAWN, ALMOST
LIKE VERBATIM A LITTLE
BIT, THAT WAS A THRILL.
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE COOL.
>> YEAH.
>> FOR THE RECORD THE ONLY
THING I WAS UPSET ABOUT IS
THAT HE DIDN'T COME
BACK IN THE BLACK SUIT.
>> ME, TOO.
>> BECAUSE HENRY TWEETED OUT
THE IMAGE OF THE BLACK SUIT.
IT'S LIKE OH, THEY'RE
GOING TO DO BLACK --
>> I'M WITH YOU.
I'M YOU.
>> SORRY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WAIT FOR THE REMAKE.
>> THERE WE GO.
CAN YOU GUYS TELL US
ABOUT YOUR FIRST --
CAN YOU REMEMBER YOUR FIRST
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS CHARACTER,
WHEN YOU FIRST DISCOVERED HIM?
>> I THINK IT WAS WATCHING
THE GEORGE REEVES SHOWS
ON THE LITTLE BLACK
AND WHITE TV AT HOME.
THE COMIC COMES INTO MY
LIFE, LIKE MOST COMICS,
IN BOXES THAT OLDER KIDS ON
THE BLOCK HAD OF THEIR COMICS,
AND I'D SEE ALL THE DIFFERENT
CHARACTERS, BUT THE FIRST COMIC
THAT WAS MINE WAS ACTION 300,
WHICH A BABYSITTER BROUGHT
TO SHUT ME UP ONE NIGHT WHEN
I WAS ABOUT 5 YEARS OLD,
AND IT HAD A SUBSCRIPTION AD
WHERE FOR A DOLLAR YOU COULD
GET A SUBSCRIPTION FOR A YEAR.
AND I SOMEHOW CONNED MY PARENTS
INTO SENDING IN THE
DOLLAR FOR IT.
AND I WAS A SUBSCRIBER TO ACTION
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
AFTER THAT.
>> TALK ABOUT A DOLLAR
WELL SPENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT SORT OF PAID
OFF ULTIMATELY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> THE FIRST TIME I EVER
BOUGHT WAS A SUPERMAN COMIC,
IT WAS SUPERMAN 89.
IT HAD SUPERMAN ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THE COVER
AND CRYPTOWAS BARKING AT
HIM AND WEARING THE CAPE.
HE DOES NOT HAVE THE CAPE ON.
SUPERMAN IS SAYING OR THINKING,
BECAUSE THEY DID THOUGHT
BALLOONS IN THOSE DAYS,
SAID EVEN MY DOG CRYPTO
DOESN'T RECOGNIZE ME
WHICH IF YOU'RE A KID,
ALL RIGHT, I'LL BUY THAT.
LET'S SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
SO MY FIRST COMIC
WAS A SUPERMAN COMIC.
>> FOR THE RECORD MY FIRST WAS
WHEN HE REVEALED HIS
IDENTITY TO LOIS.
WHICH WAS IN ACTION COMICS.
>> THAT WAS A POINT OF SOME
DISCUSSION, BECAUSE WHEN
THAT STORY WAS ORIGINALLY
PLANNED, AND WE HAD A GROUP
OF WRITERS IN THE ROOM THAT
TALKED ABOUT IT AND SET IT UP,
THAT WASN'T SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN.
THEY WERE GOING TO GET
ENGAGED AND THEN IN THE MIDDLE
OF PUTTING THE STORY TOGETHER,
A COUPLE OF THE GUYS CALLED ME
UP ALONG WITH OUR EDITOR
AT THE TIME, MIKE CARLIN
AND SAID WE JUST REALIZED, IF
SUPERMAN PROPOSES TO LOIS LANE
AND SHE SAYS YES
AND HE DOESN'T ADMIT
THAT CLARK KENT ADMIT HE'S
SUPERMAN HE'S LYING TO HER
AND THAT WOULD BE WRONG SO WE
TALKED ABOUT IT AT THE TIME
AND THAT'S HOW WE KIND OF
RECONFIGURED THAT SCENE,
SO IT DID PLAY OUT THAT WAY.
>> WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME, ARE WE GOING TO LEAVE TIME
FOR Q & A WITH THE AUDIENCE?
OKAY. OKAY, THERE YOU GO, SIR,
AND THEN I'LL GET
YOU IN THE BACK.
THE MIC IS COMING.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS LOOKING FOR.
[ OFF MICROPHONE ]
>> SO WHEN I WAS
READING COMICS AS A KID,
I THOUGHT THEY WERE
GEARED FOR KIDS.
GEARED FOR THE 7-YEAR-OLD.
THESE COMICS THESE
DAYS DON'T SEEM
TO BE GEARED FOR THAT AUDIENCE.
HOW DO YOU KEEP KIDS IN IT
TO GET MORE PEOPLE TURNING
INTO THE INDUSTRY, AS READERS?
>> THAT WAS A GIGANTIC
BUSINESS QUESTION IN THE 1980s
WHEN THE COMIC SHOP BECAME
THE NEW HOME OF THE FIELD
WHEN THE NEWS STAND WAS
DRYING UP, BECAUSE PREPARE
TO THE 1980s, IN AMERICA,
IF YOU WERE A KID,
COMICS WERE THE FIRST
THING YOU BOUGHT OTHER
THAN MAYBE CHEWING GUM.
AND YOU PROGRESSED FROM READING
DISNEY OR LOONY TUNES ON UP
TO GETTING THE SUPER HEROES
AND THEN YOU DISCOVERED
THE OPPOSITE SEX OR SPORTS
OR SOMETHING, AND YOU GAVE
IT UP AND YOU MOVED ON.
THE MODEL CHANGED, AND FOR A FEW
YEARS THERE WE WERE PETRIFIED
THAT WE'RE NEVER GOING
TO HAVE NEW KIDS,
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
NEWSSTANDS TO RECRUIT THEM WITH.
TURNED OUT THAT, IN FACT,
YOU CAN RECRUIT PEOPLE
TO START READING COMICS AT
A LATER AGE, AND STARTING
IN THE LATE '80s AND VERY
HEAVILY THROUGH THE '90s,
WE BEGAN TO SEE WAVES OF
KIDS COMING INTO THE MEDIUM
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND IN COLLEGE
YEARS, WITH THE MATERIAL
THAT WE WERE DOING
FOR OLDER PEOPLE.
IN THE LAST 10 YEARS, THERE'S
BEEN A WONDERFUL RESURGENCE
IN COMICS FOR KIDS.
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
GRAPHIC NOVEL
OF THE LAST FEW YEARS IS
THE WORK OF RENA TELGEMEYER,
WHICH CLEARLY REACHES PROBABLY
AT ITS HEART 8 TO 10-YEAR-OLDS
AND GOES OUT AT PRINT
RUNS LARGER THAN, SADLY,
ANY ISSUE OF SUPERMAN.
AND THOSE ARE KIDS WHO ARE
COMING INTO COMICS THROUGH THAT.
NOT ALL OF THEM WILL
BE INTERESTED
IN SUPERMAN AFTERWARDS.
BUT SOME OF THEM WILL BE.
SOME OF THEM WILL
MOVE THROUGH IT.
AND I'M REALLY COMFORTABLE
AT THIS POINT
THAT WE'RE RECRUITING A LOT OF
NEW PEOPLE OF ALL AGES TO COME
INTO THE COMICS, AND
THEY'RE JUST COMING
IN THROUGH VERY DIVERSE
PATHS, NOT THE SAME EXACT PATH
THAT MY GENERATION CAME IN.
IT'S A DIFFERENT TIME.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I SEE
THAT HAS DEFINITELY INCREASED
OVER THE YEARS IS, IT'S VERY
OFTEN I'LL HEAR SOMEONE YOUR AGE
WILL SAY THIS IS
MY FAVORITE COMIC.
SOMEONE WILL PUT DOWN
A TRADE PAPERBACK
AND SAY THIS WAS MY
FIRST COMIC AND ONE
OF THE BARRIERS I THINK WAS
ALWAYS THERE WAS THIS IDEA THEY
COULDN'T NECESSARILY GET
THAT 7 YEAR-OLD COULDN'T GET
THE ENTIRE STORY IN AN ISSUE
BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE PART
3 OF A 6 PART STORY.
NOW WHEN THEY PUT DOWN THE TRADE
PAPERBACK THEY HAVE THE WHOLE
STORY AND THAT'S WHAT
I SEE MORE AND MORE.
THEY'RE GIVING ME A BOOK.
>> DC ALSO HAS A GREAT GATEWAY
AND THE TEEN TITANS GIRL CARTOON
WHICH IS A PHENOMENAL WAY TO GET
KIDS INTERESTED IN CHARACTERS.
NEXT QUESTION?
RIGHT HERE?
>> GOOD EVENING.
THERE WE GO.
JUST WANT TO START OFF BY
SAYING THANK YOU TO YOU BOTH
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO DO THIS.
I THINK IT'S A VERY COOL
AND I'M SURE EVERYONE
IN THE AUDIENCE APPRECIATES
YOU TOOK THE TIME TO DO IT.
SO THANK YOU TO YOU BOTH.
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT LEX LUTHOR
AND IT TIES BACK INTO AN
EARLIER QUESTION BROUGHT
UP ABOUT THE THOUGHT PROCESS
THAT SUPERMAN IS TOO POWERFUL,
THAT HE'S BORING BECAUSE
THERE'S NO THREAT TO HIM BUT,
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
I MAKE THE COMPARISON
TO THE MODERN DAY INTERPRETATION
OF LEX VERSUS THE FILMS,
WHEN I'M READING OF LEX IN
THE MODERN DAY COMIC BOOKS,
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST THAT
HUMANITY HAS TO OFFER
IN THE INTELLECT,
THE PROWESS, THE WILL
AND THAT'S WHY SUPERMAN
TAKES HIM SO SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE HE RECOGNIZES THAT
AND HE KNOWS THIS GUY IS
COMMITTED TO TAKING HIM DOWN.
BUT THEN WHEN I LOOK AT
THE FILM, EVEN GOING BACK
TO SUPERMAN THE MOVIE,
THERE'S AN ELEMENT OF KIND
OF OVER THE TOPNESS,
AND HAMMINESS
THAT THE LEX LUTHOR
CHARACTER IS PRO TRAYED
AND IT'S HARD THEIRTIVELY TO
PORTRAY THEM TO THE AUDIENCE
AND THINK THAT'S A CHARACTER
SUPERMAN WILL TAKE SERIOUSLY
AS A THREAT.
UNLIKE THE JOKER WHERE
HIS OVER THE TOPNESS PLAYS
INTO THE PSYCHOTIC NATURE AND
MAKES IT MORE THREATENING,
I THINK THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY PLAY
WITH THE CHARACTER
LEX LUTHOR IN REGARDS
TO HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH SUPERMAN.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING
WHY YOU THINK
THAT ELEMENT KEEPS MAKING
ITS WAY INTO THE FILM,
THEN NOT NECESSARILY
TAKING THE CUES
FROM THE MODERN DAY
INTERPRETATION OF LEX LUTHOR?
>> I THINK IN SOME WAYS, YOU
KNOW, LEX MIGHT HAVE BEEN CHOSEN
FOR THE FILM AND PORTRAYED THOSE
WAYS BECAUSE HE WAS FAMILIAR,
BUT TO BACKTRACK A LITTLE BIT
ON YOUR QUESTION, WHICH IS,
IS IT HARD TO WRITE FOR SUPERMAN
BECAUSE OF THE POWER LEVEL?
AND ESPECIALLY WITH
REGARDS TO LEX LUTHOR,
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT LEVEL OF POWER?
I THINK YOU WRITE A GOOD
STORY BY TESTING CHARACTER
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU FIND
OUT WITH A SUPERMAN STORY
AND I DON'T FIND THAT
HARD TO WRITE FOR.
YOU TEST SUPERMAN'S CHARACTER
SOMEHOW AND IF YOU TAKE SOMEONE
LIKE LEKS LUTHOR, WHO IS
SO DEVIOUS AND INTELLIGENT
AND CRAFTY THERE SHOULD
BE MANY WAYS FOR HIM
TO TEST SUPERMAN SOMEHOW.
EVEN IF HE STANDS
INSIDE LEX'S OFFICE
WHERE HE COULD USE HIS X-RAY
VISION TO LOOK AT ANY DATA
OR LISTEN TO ANY CONVERSATION
THAT NONE OF THAT APPEARS
IN THE OFFICE BECAUSE
LEX IS TOO SMART
SO THERE ARE ALWAYS GOOD WAYS
TO DO THAT KIND OF A STORY
AND I THINK THE FACT THAT
LEX DOESN'T HAVE SUPER-POWERS
WHEN PITTED AGAINST SUPERMAN
IS PART OF WHAT MAKES
THAT DYNAMIC SO INTERESTING.
>> I RECALL THAT ONE OF
THE I THINK MAYBE THE BEST
EXPLANATIONS I EVER SAW WAS I
THINK IT WAS A JUSTICE LEAGUE
COMIC, BUT A CHARACTER
WITH ACTION SUPERMAN,
WHY ARE YOU SO WORRIED
ABOUT HIM?
HE SAYS, I CAN'T SEE
WHAT HE'S THINKING
AND HE'S ALWAYS THINKING.
SO I JUST, THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THAT CHARACTER NOT COMING
THROUGH IN THE FILMS, I WONDER
WHY THAT HASN'T HAPPENED.
>> I THINK IT'S ALSO, THE GUYS
ASKED ME TO DO A LITTLE SUPERMAN
AND LEX STORY THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE HARDCOVER,
WHICH I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF HAVING WORKING
WITH KNEEL ADAMS ON.
IT'S AMAZING -- NEIL ADAMS ON.
IT'S AMAZING.
AND THE STORY CENTERS AROUND
THE IDEA THAT BECAUSE LEX IS
SUCH A REPRESENTATIVE OF WHAT
IS STRONG IN THE HUMAN RACE,
AS WELL AS WHAT WENT WRONG,
SUPERMAN DOESN'T
WANT TO DEFEAT HIM.
HE WANTS TO WIN HIM
OVER ON SOME LEVEL.
AND IT'S JUST A LITTLE STORY
OF SUPERMAN GOING TO PLAY CHESS
WITH LEX LUTHOR,
BECAUSE HE KEEPS HOPING
THAT IF HE JUST SITS DOWN
AND SHOWS LEX THE RIGHT WAY
TO THINK, THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME WAY TO GET THROUGH TO HIM,
CONVINCE HIM THAT SUPERMAN IS
NOT A BAD THING FOR THE WORLD,
BUT ALSO HAVE LEX BE A GOOD PART
OF THE WORLD, AND LIKE SUPERMAN,
MAKE THE CHOICE TO USE
HIS PERSONAL GIFTS,
HIS PERSONAL ABILITIES,
FOR THE RIGHT CAUSES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> DOESN'T NECESSARILY WORK
OUT AS SUPERMAN INTENDED.
>> EXCUSE ME.
THANKS A LOT.
I REALLY CAN'T SAY HOW
MUCH I'VE ENJOYED BOTH
OF YOUR WORK OVER THE YEARS.
AND IN PARTICULAR, MR. LEVITZ,
THE GREAT DARKNESS SAGA.
I'M GEEING OUT.
I WAS IN COLLEGE AT THE TIME.
IT WAS SOMETHING TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE 20 MINUTES AND GET A BREAK
FROM COLLEGE TO GO INTO A
WHOLE OTHER DIFFERENT WORLD.
THAT SAID, I GUESS IN A FEW
DAYS IS THE 60th ANNIVERSARY
OF THE LEGION OF SUPERHEROS
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS,
ONE OF THE WAYS I'VE ALWAYS
ENJOYED SUPERMAN IS THE
INTERACTION WITH OTHER
CHARACTERS AND I DON'T KNOW
IF EITHER OF YOU HAVE SOMETHING
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE ABOUT THAT.
>> I THINK IT'S ALWAYS FUN.
PART OF IT IS THAT
WHENEVER WE PUT CHARACTERS
LIKE THAT TOGETHER, WE FIND
OUT WHAT MAKES THEM GIVEN
FROM ONE ANOTHER AND IT'S ALWAYS
FUN TO SEE THAT CHARACTER MIX.
AND SOME OF THEM CAN
BE QUITE SPECIAL.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN
THE SUPERMAN-BATMAN DYNAMIC.
MORE RECENTLY THE
SUPERMAN-WONDER WOMAN DYNAMIC.
CERTAINLY WITH THE LEGION,
WHERE SUPERBOY WAS FLAT-OUT
INSPIRATION FOR THEM TO EXIST,
THAT'S SORT OF LIKE THE ULTIMATE
COMBINATION OF CHARACTERS THERE.
>> THAT'S THE FIRST STUFF
WE GOT TO DO TOGETHER.
>> YEAH.
>> TOWARDS THE BEGINNING OF
YOUR CAREER AS AN ARTIST, RIGHT?
>> MM-HMM, YEP.
>> I AGREE COMPLETELY
WITH WHAT DAN SAID.
THE OTHER THING I THINK
THAT'S KEY ON THAT IS
WHEN YOU PUT SUPERMAN
AMONG THE OTHER HEROES,
YOU REALLY SEE HIS
ICONIC NATURE,
BECAUSE HE'S FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE REST OF THEM.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER HEROES
THAT HAVE INCREDIBLE POWERS,
BUT IN THIS MYTHOLOGY,
HE'S THE PRIMAL FIGURE,
AND YOU SEE PEOPLE REACTING TO
HIM THAT WAY, AND IT'S KIND OF,
IF THOMAS JEFFERSON SHOWED UP
HERE AND WANTED TO GO DIGGING
THROUGH SOME OF THE
BOOKS IN THE LIBRARY,
IT WOULD BE A VERY
DIFFERENT REACTION
THAN THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
POLITICIAN
THAT YOU COULD POSSIBLY FIND
IN WASHINGTON TODAY SHOWING UP
AND WANTING TO DO THAT RESEARCH.
>> YEAH.
>> I THANK YOU BOTH.
THIS HAS BEEN A REALLY
AWESOME EVENT.
I LOVE SUPERMAN A LOT
AND IT'S AWESOME TO TALK
ABOUT THE MAN OF STEEL.
I ACTUALLY WANT TO
DIG A LITTLE DEEPER
INTO THE BATMAN-SUPERMAN
RELATIONSHIP SPECIFICALLY.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT INTERPRETATIONS
BASED ON, YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN FIND SOMETHING WHERE
THEY'RE FLAT-OUT ENEMIES.
YOU CAN FIND THINGS
WHERE THEY'RE FRENEMIES,
YOU CAN FIND THINGS WHERE
THEY'RE THE BEST OF FRIENDS,
THERE'S A TRUST BUT
VERIFY RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM.
I'M INTERESTED, HOW DO YOU
BOTH VIEW THAT RELATIONSHIP?
SHOULD THERE BE SOME ANTAGONISM,
SHOULD THERE BE SOME TENSION?
OR IS THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
ALMOST LIKE A RELIC AND SHOULD
THAT BE DISPOSED OF TO TELL
NEW STORIES ABOUT BATMAN
AND SUPERMAN IN THAT
RELATIONSHIP?
>> I HAVE NEVER APPROACHED IT
AS THOUGH THEY'RE
THE BEST OF BUDDIES.
I THINK THERE IS AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF MUTUAL RESPECT
ON BOTH SIDES, BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY,
I THINK THEY OPERATE
IN VERY DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND BECAUSE THEY OPERATE
IN VERY DIFFERENT WAYS,
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH SUPERMAN
CATEGORICALLY APPROVES.
DOESN'T MEAN HE DISAPPROVES.
BUT I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS --
I THINK IT'S BETTER WHEN
THERE'S SOME TENSION THERE.
YOU KNOW, BATMAN IS A
CREATURE OF THE NIGHT.
SUPERMAN IS OF THE SUN.
BATMAN WEARS THE MASK.
SUPERMAN DOES NOT.
ALL THAT STUFF, IT'S
THERE AS A DIFFERENCE,
BUT THOSE DIFFERENCES
MEAN SOMETHING,
AND I ALWAYS THINK IT'S BEEN
A LITTLE FORCED JUST TO SAY
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN A
TITLE FOR SO LONG THAT WAS
IN THE WORLD'S FINEST
COMICS THAT THEY HAVE
TO BE THE BEST OF BUDDIES.
THEY SEEM TOO DIFFERENT
THAN THAT TO ME.
AND YEAH, OPPOSITES ATTRACT
BUT I STILL THINK THEY'RE TOO
DIFFERENT FROM ONE ANOTHER.
>> I AGREE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING, DAN.
I JUST DON'T THINK THEY'D BE
COMFORTABLE WITH EACH OTHER.
>> RIGHT.
>> THERE'S GOT TO BE A PART
OF BATMAN THAT LOOKS AND SAYS:
JESUS, IF I HAD THOSE POWERS,
I WOULD JUST DESTROY EVERY GUN
IN GOTHAM CITY IN ONE NIGHT.
I'D RUN FROM BUILDING TO
BUILDING TO BUILDING DOING THIS.
THE THINGS I WOULD BE ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH WITH IT.
AND SUPERMAN AT THE
SAME TIME WOULD LOOK
AT THE METHODOLOGY
BATMAN USES, THE EMPHASIS
ON FEAR, AND BE TURNED OFF.
IT WOULD BE SOMETHING HE'D
JUST BE TOTALLY UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH ON SOME VERY BASIC LEVEL.
IT'S CHALLENGING WRITING
ANYTHING LIKE JUSTICE LEAGUE,
BECAUSE YOU BRING TOGETHER
CHARACTERS WHO HAVE
SUCH FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW.
ON ONE LEVEL, IT'S GREAT BECAUSE
YOU REALLY AS DAN WAS SAYING,
YOU GET TO SHOW THE
CONFLICT POINTS BETWEEN THEM
THAT HEIGHTEN THE RELATIONSHIPS.
AND WE RECOGNIZE IT AS PEOPLE.
IT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN THE
RELATIONSHIPS WE SEE IN MEMBERS
OF A SPORTS TEAM WHO ARE BROUGHT
TOGETHER FOR THE SAME GOAL,
BUT ONE OF THEM'S A SHOW-OFF
AND THE OTHER ONE IS A
GREAT TEAM PLAYER AND ONE
OF THEM'S ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THE NEXT PLAY MIGHT BE
AND TALKING TO THE COACH
AND OUTTHINKING THEM.
SO IT'S VERY HUMAN
AND RECOGNIZABLE.
BUT IT'S VERY CHALLENGING TO
PUT THAT TOGETHER AND SAY:
WOULD THEY STAY TOGETHER?
WOULD THEY PLAY NICELY TOGETHER?
>> HEY, PROFESSOR.
HOW ARE YOU?
IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
IT'S ANDREW DAVIS.
>> HELLO THERE.
>> SO MY QUESTION IS
PIGGYBACKING OFF THE BATMAN
QUESTION THAT WAS JUST
ASKED, SO NIGHTFALL CAME OUT
AND SUPERMAN CAME OUT
RELATIVELY CLOSE TO EACH OTHER.
HOW WERE YOU TWO FEELING WHEN
THOSE TWO BOOKS CAME OUT?
AND WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR HEAD ON THEM COMPETING
WITH EACH OTHER, OR NOT
COMPETING WITH EACH OTHER?
>> MY THOUGHT WAS, OH, MY GOD,
WE'RE SELLING SO MANY COMICS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THOSE WERE GOOD DAYS.
>> THERE WAS A PERIOD THERE
OF ABOUT 6 MONTHS OR A YEAR
WHERE WE WERE HAVING WEEKLY
MEETINGS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO KEEP SOME OF THESE
THINGS IN PRINT,
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
MOVING THROUGH SO QUICKLY.
AND IT WAS A PHENOMENAL MOMENT.
YOU KNOW, THE SUCCESS
OF DEATH OF SUPERMAN,
WHICH WAS REALLY THE
EXTRAORDINARY THING,
NIGHTFALL WAS SUCCESSFUL, BUT
NOWHERE NEAR IN THE SAME LEAGUE,
WAS NOT ANYTHING WE
WERE ANTICIPATING.
WE'D KILLED SUPERMAN BEFORE.
WE'D KILLED HIM A
COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS.
WE KILLED HIM DIFFERENT TIMES.
THEY WERE NICE STORIES.
YOU CAN ARGUE THAT THE
JERRY SIEGEL VERSION
OF KILLING SUPERMAN
IN THE '60s WAS ONE
OF THE BEST SUPERMAN STORIES
OF THE 1960s, BUT ULTIMATELY
IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF
THINGS NOBODY CARED.
THE RUN THAT DAN WORKED ON WITH
MIKE CARLIN AND THE WHOLE REST
OF THE TEAM, WHETHER IT
WAS BECAUSE IT FIRST HIT --
THE NEWS OF IT FIRST HIT ON A
SLOW NEWS DAY OR THE ZEITGEIST
OF THE WORLD HAD CHANGED, A
BUNCH OF THINGS CAME TOGETHER,
AND WE WERE JUST STANDING THERE
WITH A BASKET CATCHING MANNA
FROM HEAVEN FOR A WHILE.
THIS WAS A VERY EARLY
DAYS OF DOING ANY KIND
OF GRAPHIC NOVEL FORMAT
TRADE PAPERBACK OR ANYTHING,
AND WE WANTED TO DO
A ONE-VOLUME EDITION
OF THE FIRST DEATH STORY.
WE HAD SOLD SO MANY
COPIES OF THE INDIVIDUAL,
SO MANY PRINTINGS, I
REMEMBER VERY VIVIDLY,
THE GUYS WHO HANDLED THE NEWS
STAND SIDE OF OUR BUSINESS,
THE MASS MARKET DISTRIBUTION,
COMING IN AND THEY WANTED COPIES
OF THIS ONE-VOLUME TRADE
PAPERBACK WE WERE DOING.
WELL, THAT WAS A
RETURNABLE BUSINESS,
SO THE MORE COPIES
YOU PRINTED FOR IT,
THE MORE RISK YOU WERE TAKING.
AND THE NORMAL PRINT
RUN THAT YOU WOULD DO
FOR SENDING SOMETHING TO
THE NEWSSTAND IN COMICS
AT THAT POINT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
50,000 OR 100,000 COPIES,
AT MOST, OF SOMETHING.
AND USUALLY IT WAS A COMIC
BOOK THAT WAS A PROBABLY
AT THAT TIME A DOLLAR
COMIC OR A 75-CENT COMIC,
SO THE COST TO PRINT
WASN'T VERY MUCH.
IT WASN'T AN ENORMOUS
RISK TO PUT IT OUT THERE.
WE SAID ALL RIGHT, LOOK AND SEE
HOW MANY YOU THINK WE CAN MOVE
THROUGH THE NEWSSTANDS.
THEY CAME BACK AND SAID:
OKAY, WE NEED 650,000.
AND THIS WAS $3.95 I THINK
FOR THE FIRST VERSION.
>> $4.95. AND RIGHT BEFORE
CHRISTMAS TOO, RIGHT?
>> SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHAT WAS REALLY
A MIRACLE IS THE SPEED
WITH WHICH YOU PULLED
IT TOGETHER.
>> NORMALLY SPEAKING, YOU'D
EXPECT IF YOU WERE SUCCESSFUL
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO SELL
HALF OF THE COPIES YOU SHIPPED,
MAYBE 1/3 OF THE COPIES AND
THE REST WOULD COME BACK
AND BE DEAD TREES.
AND -- BUT YOU ALSO MIGHT
GET ALL OF THEM BACK
AND WE HADN'T SENT OUT
600,000 OF ANYTHING
TO THE NEWSSTAND FOR, GOD,
20 YEARS AT THAT POINT.
BUT WE HAD MADE ENOUGH MONEY
OFF THE PERIODICAL COPIES
THAT WE SAID: OKAY, WE CAN
AFFORD TO GAMBLE THIS THIS YEAR
AND WE PRINTED THE 650,000,
OR WHATEVER IT WAS,
AND WE SENT IT OUT.
AND THEY ALL SOLD.
IT WAS AN AMAZING YEAR.
>> GOT TIME FOR ONE
MORE QUESTION.
IT'S GOT TO BE REALLY GOOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DO YOU GET TO PICK DOOMSDAY
WHO GOT THE DEATH TO SUPERMAN?
OR DID DC PICK?
>> HELP ME OUT.
WHAT ABOUT PICKING
THE DEATH OF SUPERMAN?
DID WE...
>> DID YOU GET TO PICK DOOMSDAY?
OR DID DC PICK DOOMSDAY?
>> WELL, WE DECIDED TO DO
THE DEATH OF SUPERMAN, RIGHT?
AND ACTUALLY, I HAD
TWO STORIES WRITTEN --
OR TWO IDEAS WRITTEN
ON A YELLOW LEGAL PAD.
ONE WAS DEATH OF SUPERMAN.
AND THE OTHER ONE WAS
MONSTER TRASHES METROPOLIS.
ON ANOTHER SHEET RIGHT UNDER
THAT ONE I HAD A SKETCH
OF A MONSTER WITH SOME BONES
SORT OF STICKING OUT OF HIM.
THIS WAS ON A YELLOW LEGAL PAD.
WE STARTED TALKING ABOUT A STORY
CALLED THE DEATH OF SUPERMAN.
WE WERE SEVERAL WRITERS
AND ARTISTS
AND OUR EDITORIAL TEAM
ALL IN THE ROOM TOGETHER,
AND WE STARTED TO FOCUS ON IT
AND THOUGHT THAT WOULD WORK OUT.
BUT WE STILL DIDN'T HAVE
A NAME FOR THE MONSTER
OR ANYTHING ELSE, AND OUR EDITOR
WROTE: DOOMSDAY FOR SUPERMAN
AT THE TOP OF THE BOARD.
AND WE THEN SAID: WAIT!
BECAUSE BACK THEN
EVERYBODY HAD CRAZY NAMES.
IT WAS BLOOD THIS AND BLOOD
THAT IN A LOT OF WAYS.
AND I THINK IT WAS ME BUT
I'M NOT 100% SURE SAID:
IS THERE ANYBODY
CALLED DOOMSDAY?
AND WE ALL START, DOOMSDAY?
NO, THERE'S NOT SO THAT'S
HOW HE GOT THE NAME DOOMSDAY
AND I HAD A LITTLE SKETCH RIGHT
THERE, SO WE SORT OF PICKED IT
BUT THEN BECAUSE
WE HAD AN EDITOR
IN THE ROOM, DC WENT FOR IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WAS THAT HARRY?
>> NO, THAT CAME LATER.
THAT WAS A MEETING
OR TWO LATER I THINK.
>> THE TWO OF YOU WERE NICE
ENOUGH, TO AWACHTLY HAVE ONE
OF THE FIRST COPIES
OF THE CELEBRATION
OF 80 YEARS ACTION COMICS.
THIS ISN'T THE PERIODICAL,
THIS IS ACTUALLY THE COLLECTION
THAT PAUL EDITED AND PUT
TOGETHER, BECAUSE REMEMBER,
THERE ARE TWO VERSIONS
COMING OUT.
YOU GUYS HAVE SIGNED THIS COPY
FOR THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS,
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO ON BEHALF OF EVERYONE
HERE, AND PAUL AND DAN,
WE'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING
OUT TO THIS VERY
FUN CONVERSATION.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU!
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND THANK YOU ALL.
>>This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.